en los escombros de la torre de
televisión de rifle se encuentran los
cuerpos de unos 20 soldados
[Aplausos]
el gobernador regional prometió
restablecer la emisión en dos días y
elogió a los socorristas
hicieron todo lo que pudieron el ataque
tuvo lugar a las 5 22 de la mañana el
primer equipo llegó a las 527 y bajó los
estudios de televisión del centro de la
ciudad el sótano donde se almacenan los
equipos antiguos se ha convertido en un
refugio la ciudad de rubén no se vio
afectada pero el sonido de las sirenas
es cotidiano
dos o tres veces tuvimos que interrumpir
las noticias de la televisión a causa de
las sirenas siempre acudimos al refugio
cuando los oímos durante nuestro trabajo
pero después de lo sucedido el lunes
somos aún más cuidadosos intentamos
correr aquí aún más rápido no es
casualidad que hayan golpeado la torre
de televisión porque su objetivo es
impedir que la gente acceda a la
información
el refugio también es utilizado por los
vecinos del barrio como lec
el lunes por la mañana la televisión
dejó de emitir
una vez levantada la alerta nos invitó a
su casa
no funciona ni un solo canal en los
pueblos la gente está realmente
preocupada de repente no hay noticias en
un momento en el que realmente quieren
saber qué está pasando en la ciudad la
gente puede recibir la televisión por
cable o por internet
de tiana que acaba de regresar del
refugio se prepara para la misión
seguimos con los informativos mientras
estábamos allí y gracias a dios no pasa
nada
quiere seguir trabajando
siento que me necesitan aquí esa es una
de las razones por las que me quedo pero
también es porque sencillamente no
quiero dejar mi ciudad sin embargo su
noticiero publica el perfil de un
voluntario local que está llevando a la
gente a polonia un destino que está en
la mente de todos